this along this team of trying different
settings so here only so I yeah I'm not
a theoretician but maybe you will find
the topic interesting and as a theorist
maybe you'll see that some would be
great to work together if you see
anything so started with this image is
in Paris spending two days searching for
a needle in a haystack does anyone know
why it's in my slide deck okay I guess
take it yes someone take a guess
usually someone let's go it could be
related so he's he's in a gallery this
is like installation art and at the
gallery he's looking literally for
heat'll and the gallery is warned that
it might take longer than expected and
so we're kind of faced with that when we
want to do protein and small molecule
design fundamentally this is a search
problem and when you first look at it
you can think of it as sort of
combinatorial optimization but sort of
every turn you take and trying to solve
this in a real way in the wet lab and
move forward you find that it's much
more nuanced than that and so basically
this talk is gonna take you through that
perspective of how we think about doing
protein and small molecule design as
some sort of an optimization problem
which depends very heavily on machine
learning so why do we want to do this so
there are a lot of naturally occurring
proteins that are used day to day that
are super super important so this is a
fluorescent tagging protein you put it
in and you can see particular elements
of something this is used day to day in
research in pharmaceutical it's and it
believed one of the Nobel Prizes went to
that one so something else there's a
protein called Rubisco and it's sort of
the rate-limiting it's involved in the
rate limiting step of photosynthesis has
to do with carbon fixation and and and
it as i'll tell you we would like
potentially to optimize these and other
proteins but i'm just giving you some
examples of why these are really
important something else is that
proteins but your antibodies can act as
drugs so they can bind to drug targets
and sort of shut things down
when they're not operating well and I'm
not going to talk about it in this talk
but you may have heard of CRISPR gene
editing on which I've done some some
computational work but one of the key
elements here is a protein which are
sort of the computational scissors and
they go in and they pull apart the DNA
and they cut it and people and since is
also another place where proteins are
really important so we'd like to
actually often re-engineer these
proteins that already exist either to
make them better or to for new tasks or
we'd like to even just a novo design
proteins and small molecules so I keep
saying proteins and small molecules I'm
going to anchor this talk on proteins
they're a little bit easier for reasons
I'll maybe mention briefly but the the
computational methods and challenges
that I'm discussed you know discuss
these are appropriate to both so right
so for the proteins that fluoresce we
may want to change their wavelength or
we may just want to make them as intense
as possible so we can see them really
well there's sort of two things that are
in tension here which are called box
elation and oo oxygenation and if we
could tweak the protein to somehow do
better on both of those this would be
really useful for environmental reasons
for agriculture for all kinds of things
and it's a it's a long-standing problem
on how to design better antibodies and
finally as I said for this CRISPR gene
editing you may want to design it so
that it's more specific to the task and
there are served less exit accidental
edits or cuts in the genome but so I
know all these cases these are proteins
and as you may already know proteins are
represented by a sequence from an
alphabet of amino acids so each of these
is say a different protein a very short
protein they're usually much longer than
this and the idea is that some of these
for example they're actually in this
case they're not that example but that's
similar but certain ones will fool that
you know each one has different
properties and so in some times we want
to design a sequence that has the
properties we want and that may be
several properties I might I'm gonna
focus on one property for most of this
talk so there's an abstract concept so
why is this difficult so effectively
we're searching through some huge
combinatorial space right and so this is
really difficult question
one sequence or you can get things that
have to interact with each other sort of
two subunits I'm not gonna go there
right now I'm gonna focus on like the
kind of core concept which is the
predominant one which is a single string
which is one protein sometimes for a
protein to function it needs a partner
and they have to somehow fit together in
particular ways but that's a sort of
downstream and so obviously the scales
really badly and for very reasonable
sized proteins is already like an
impossible impractical intractable
problem so it's also a discrete search
space that we can't use gradients which
elsewhere of course and we're gonna at
some point use a predictive model which
is deep neural network which is part of
the reason I guess I'm speaking here and
we're gonna care a lot about uncertainty
in that model which is also going to end
extrapolation and these are both going
to be very difficult challenges so right
so the rest of this talk is basically me
explaining to you how we're thinking
about this problem as a statistical
machine learning based optimization
problem and there's first there's sort
of two sections one is a little kind of
first an introduction and an overview of
how it's actually done in the lab right
now and how at first glance you might do
this computationally which is what we
actually did in our workshop paper until
we thought a bit more deeply about how
that can go wrong and so I'll tell you
about that and then leave you with what
I think are some interesting challenges
okay so how do people actually do this
now you may not be aware but just last
year Francis Arnold whose Excel tech got
the Nobel Prize in Chemistry for
something called directed evolution this
is a main technique that people use for
protein engineering now it has no
computational component it's a pure wet
lab thing and obviously it works really
well because they got the Nobel Prize
and so the name actually sort of
describes already what it does but let
me take you through that to make sure
you understand because we're gonna
essentially build a computational analog
to that so what you do is you start with
some parent protein imagine you care
about maximizing the intensity of a
protein and so you sort of one that
maybe if fluoresce is a little bit and
your goal is to make it fluoresce more
so what you do is you induce some
diversification step so you can think
you have some starting sequence and it's
actually a protein and then you say
throw x-rays at the protein and now it's
going to mutate spontaneously
and different proteins will have mutated
in different ways so you don't some
different number of mutations in
different locations and two different
letters and so now you've induced a sort
of variant pool of things related to the
initial parent and now what's your news
you're gonna direct the evolution what
does that mean you're gonna essentially
define the Fitness function
it's not gonna be survival it's gonna be
whatever you want so the in this case of
intensity you choose those you have to
measure how intense each protein is and
then you have to keep the top-performing
ones and then you repeat the process and
you keep going so so that's how it's
done now and as a computational person
you can probably immediately see
something that's sort of not optimal
about this this is sort of a
combinatorial optimization and you're
basically doing a greedy random search
and so this is probably not an effective
way to move through this search space
and so there's sort of the motivation
for everything I'm gonna tell you about
is can we move through that space more
effectively so the first thing we're
gonna do is we're gonna replace the
screening step which is typically done
in a lab right with some arduous
laboratory measurement about the
property or properties we care about or
epoxies to them and so we're gonna build
a predictive model here in many cases a
deeper whole network and that's gonna be
both good and bad but as far as I'm
gonna do the more interesting thing is
actually replacing the random greedy
search with something that's more
intelligent because there's a whole
field of optimization maybe we can make
use of this so traditionally when we
want to predict so I'm right now I'm
talking about this this part replacing
the assay with a predictive model so
many people have worked on these things
for certain properties and it's sort of
historically people always first predict
the structure of a protein and then they
predict a function because it's thought
that structure predicts function but
actually increasingly there's enough
data that people are now bypassing this
and just going directly from sequence to
the function and so in fact that's I
mean we're kind of agnostic to how our
predictive model works in some sense if
some if there's a domain where there's a
good predictive model whether it goes
through here or not we don't care but I
think generally the field is going in
this direction so what are we gonna do
about this step right I'm not gonna talk
a lot about building these models but
I'm going to talk a lot of problems
of the fact that we rely on these models
so how are we gonna replace this random
greedy search with something more
intelligent we're gonna start with the
predictive model I just described and so
in general it's gonna be four different
properties as I mentioned and maybe you
want to maximize one subject to that
another one is above threshold but for
the purpose of this talk again I'm gonna
anchor it on just maximizing one
property and you can generalize from
there so now imagine you have a
predictive model we're gonna we call
this our stochastic Oracle what we want
to do is we want to turn it on its head
right we want to after it's been we
assume it's trained and it's been given
to us and in fact we don't even care if
we can see the inside or not because
this is gonna be a black box
optimization because it's over a
discrete space and as I said gradients
can't really help us there but so we're
gonna specify the properties we want say
that this is maximal this is above some
threshold and then we want to then find
these sort of inputs of the predictive
model that satisfy that and we're over
we actually want to find more than just
one because if we go back to our
laboratory collaborators we want to give
them a handful of good bets and we want
them to be diverse to sort of maximize a
chance that we've found something useful
and so this is one what this is sort of
where the uncertainty comes in you can
imagine that we're going to care a lot
about the predictive models uncertainty
over the properties we care about this
is an example of a GP we're near the
data it has a narrower distribution and
then as you go further away it increases
in uncertainty this would be a string of
amino acid from the amino acid in this
chart yeah yeah this would be you would
start with one protein sequence so like
one of
what just one sequence like this would
be the parent you can also start with a
few if you wanted to in the cycle so all
of these are such sequences we start
with one and then we expanded into a
pool in the neural network okay I see
the neural network is just a function
that maps from amino acid space to the
properties of interest with a
probability distribution over it and in
its abstract right now and it will be
helped explain how it gets used it
hasn't but yeah roughly speaking it's
the assay measurement it's the step in
the lab where you go and say how well
did I adhere to my property that's
basically instead of measuring it we're
going to make a call to this so this is
this is one of the nuances is it's like
what I mean what constraints we want
also to be able to incorporate prior
knowledge of constraints which actually
I'll show you how we can do that but
ideally they I mean in a perfect
scenario this Oracle would encode all of
that in practice that's not usually the
case for proteins it's relatively easy
what because any any sequence of amino
acids is a valid protein now it may not
fold or anything like this but by
definition it's a protein when you get
to small molecules this is a much much
harder problem because you have to
encode what is a graph structure into
some sort of the string and so you get
into all kinds of other issues so okay
so how are we gonna think about this now
I'm sort of slowly leading you through
how do we how we think about this
problem is given the ability to predict
some property of interest such as from
that neural network say it goes from DNA
or amino acid space to a property like
protein fluorescence we want again a
method that's going to tell us what
sequence to choose to say maximize that
property and as has just been mentioned
we also want to be able to add
constraints to this design space so
maybe we know that the DNA
codes for a particular protein and that
pins it down a lot or maybe we want to
pin down the secondary structure like
the topology of the protein in a
particular way and operate only in that
space so that's the sort of formal set
up of problem that we'd like to handle
and as I mentioned this is gonna be a
black box stochastic Oracle partly so
that we can just plug and play with
domain knowledge and models out there
that may not be differentiable and also
because we're designing over a discreet
inputs here okay so in the first
approach this is sort of what we decided
we want to do we're gonna use some sort
of black box Oracle we're gonna account
for uncertainty of the Oracle predictive
model because that's obviously very
important and then we wanted to provide
a good set of candidates not just one
you can imagine you can just do gradient
descent on that neural network as they
do and sort of computer vision to
generate images but that's only gonna
give you one you can kind of do multiple
restarts and stuff but we're actually
gonna take a different approach that we
think is better something I don't this
isn't sort of I don't have yet to find
one term that is commonly used across
many fields but we've started to call
this model based optimization and I'll
explain a little bit what that means so
in standard optimization you think of
some function f and you're trying to
find the X that maximizes it and X here
is the space of say amino acid sequences
and in model-based optimization you
convert this problem into one that is in
some cases equivalent and now instead of
searching over X you search over the
parameters of a probability distribution
over X and and when this this
distribution if it has the capacity to
put a point mass on the solution then
these are equivalent and otherwise
they're not as you might ask why are we
doing this so there's some people in the
audience may know but in combinatorial
optimization people do this for
amenability of theoretical analysis and
it's also it's it's related to as well
allude to and in engineering disciplines
is this model based optimization is used
for for many reasons including but it's
black box and that you get this
distribution of things to go give to
like the like that you're going to
construct in the real world and there's
I think there are other reasons I'm not
going to go into but this is the
approach we're going to take and so this
is what I mean when I say model-based
optimization where you change from
searching over X to searching over a
distribution over X and so basically
we're going to iteratively change this
distribution from some starting point
and at the end we can sample X's from it
and these will be the proteins that we
give to our laboratory collaborators
that make sense so just as a schematic
in English we call this the search model
because basically it's a distribution
going through this space of say protein
sequences and it's gonna move around
hopefully know where we want to be once
it's there then we can sample from it
but first so it's initialized to
something that's not in the right part
of the space right if it was time the
problem would be solved so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna just sample from
it and this is kind of like this
diversification step if you will in
directed evolution then we're gonna
evaluate each of those with our function
and and then we're gonna adjust the
parameters of that model so that this
generative model favor sequences with
large values of f of X and that's
basically how and you might say okay
well how do you do this in a principled
or a rigorous way or that's more likely
to succeed and of course we're in the
space of non convex optimization so in
some sense all bets are off but some
things work better than others so right
so these are when we do this the model
can sample pretty broad areas of
sequence space it does not require the
gradients of F so we get this black box
we can incorporate uncertainty into here
if we actually use the predictive model
and it's conditional it's a CDF and we
get again we had more than one candidate
here and we can also use the tools of
probabilistic modeling which is going to
turn out to be very useful in the second
round of this okay so the this model
based optimization objective then is
we're gonna actually put a log out here
and we're gonna know this is gonna be
like the stochastic Oracle and it's
gonna say something what this means is
the probability that the intensity of
the fluorescence is higher or equal than
the maximum so in other words we're
looking for the maximum and we want to
find the distribution that does that and
so this is sort of the core beast of
what we would like to solve right now
and so this is again what we call the
search model and so you could this could
be imagine if we're in discrete space it
could be like an hmm
we've been using variational
auto-encoders we haven't yet done our
due diligence on what the best thing
would be here and then again this is the
desired set of property values for
example that the fluorescence is greater
than some threshold which could be the
maximum and then we have this stochastic
predictive model which for this this
workshop you can think of as a deep
neural network right that goes from
amino acid sequences to the property we
care about because this is the CDF it
accounts for the uncertainty and it's
also going to help us in the
optimization and as you'll see hopefully
so there are two issues with this thing
the first is that we're doing an
optimization over some parameter that
appears in the expectation distribution
this is like a very common problem in
machine learning when you see in the
very like so there's the Reaper
amortization trick and a number of other
things that people use to get around
this and we're gonna do it and in our
own way so we're gonna basically lower
bound it although I'm not gonna go in
the details here but the the bound will
actually be satiated and this allows us
to move with a parameter this is now no
longer a parameter that we're solving
for its the previous parameter and an
iterative process and so it's no longer
problematic the parameter we're
optimizing over now only lies over here
and now the other problem and this is
one that's much less common that I've
seen in machine learning as compared to
this one is that we're doing essentially
we're drawing samples and so this is a
Monte Carlo estimate and it's a rare
event estimate also which makes this
really really difficult and so what I
mean by that is initially we draw
samples from this search model and by
definition we're not in the right part
of the space and therefore the
probability that this is high like that
it's that it satisfies our desired
properties is actually quite low what
that means is this sort of the effective
sample size and so because it's a rare
event
we're doing a Monte Carlo estimate with
the really small number of samples even
if we take a large number just because
the weights are so small because it's
weighted by how well it adheres to the
property we care about does that make
sense
so what we're gonna do to solve that
problem and we've taken inspiration from
an area called the cross-entropy method
is to anneal a sequence of relaxations
and so here instead of saying that we
have to satisfy the criteria like the
intensity has to be the maximum we're
gonna slowly ramp it up so we're gonna
actually start with an intensity we've
seen and then slowly increase this
towards what we hope is the maximum but
but there's no guarantees here so right
so overall what happens is it's a it's
an iterative process where you sample
from the search distribution and once
you've done that then you find the next
parameter using what just looks like
weighted maximum likelihood and where
the weights are basically how well it
adheres to the current annealed version
of the property you care about okay so
this is actually very intuitive you can
you know get down into the details but
on but I want to just draw the very
clean and intuitive analogy between what
I've described and actually directed
evolution the wet lab method and so this
is sort of pseudocode where this is with
a stochastic Oracle this is its
expectation at CDF so we can account for
uncertainty this is what we require for
our method so this would be something
like I require a method in the
laboratory to measure the property I
care about then we have a generative
model which takes a set of weighted
samples and so this could be like a
variational auto encoder and hmm
what have you and once given these
samples it can it trains itself and then
you can sample from it so this is like
throwing x-rays at the parent and
generating versions of it that are
different and you can initialize it as
you as you do in directed evolution you
could give it a single sequence you
could also in principle give it no
sequence or you could give it a set of
sequences and now what we're gonna do is
right just take care of if it's if it's
already been initialized then just use
those otherwise randomly initialize it
and set all the weights to uniform so
basically this is just starting with a
parent or a set of parents and treating
them all equally and then we're gonna
iterate as you do in directed evolution
so we're gonna take the first we're
gonna generate samples so this is again
like throwing these x-rays at the
parents and generating a new set of
things and now what we're going to do is
we're gonna
for them according to how well they
adhere to the property we care about and
I'm not gonna go through the details
here but basically you end up waiting
each sample by both how well it does and
it counting for its uncertainty as well
as we go through this you basically have
this very similar thing to directed
evolution and we're hoping that we can
do better in some particular sweet spots
of biotechnology which I can talk a
little bit what that means what is a
sweet spot where can we apply this but
in the meantime I'm not gonna talk about
that and I just want to point out that
actually we didn't know this at the time
and it's been very interesting getting
into this space so as far as I know most
people machine-learning have not heard
about estimation of distribution
algorithms this is like a huge huge body
of literature that is really widely used
and it turns out we kind of reinvented
this in some way and and I was always
taught in grad school that evolutionary
algorithms were you know to be kind of
mocked and laughed and what's
interesting though this is kind of
modern-day equivalent to this and where
people now have replaced this that
you've probably heard of these sort of
genetic optimization algorithms of these
like kind of weird mutations and
crossovers and this is now been at least
as we've done it been sort of
incorporated into a proper statistical
framework although in 95 rich and Corona
and Beluga sort of first grabbed onto
this idea of replacing kind of these
weird mutation and crossover events with
probability distributions that capture
regularities about the space and instead
of just doing mutations randomly they're
actually doing it like this precisely
why this will work better is that you're
replacing these weird operations with
stuff in a generative model that under
hopefully he understands the space
better and the correlation between the
amino acids in this illustration and as
I mentioned that this techniques also
related to this cross-entropy method
which has originally for rare event
estimation I made probably the serve
heard of this and was actually later
sort of generalized to do maximization
for a combinatorial sort of corner
toilet organization as well and sort of
the most common EDA is something called
if you're interested in the table rate
is the covariance matrix adaptation
evolutionary strategy and this is a view
sources on Google you see this is just
like super super widely used stuff that
our community doesn't seem to to know
about but is actually using and I'll
point out there's some connections
these methods to reinforcement learning
and also to image generation action
actually we've just released a preprint
here where we have I believe for the
first time shown that these can actually
be written as variational
expectation-maximization which is pretty
astonishing that no one I think it's all
this connection yet we're trying to
leverage this connection to actually
make it work better but in the meantime
I think is a really interesting
intellectual contribution and so I just
mentioned this but these methods are
actually you can sort of not on the
surface when you look at the motivation
but if you go under the hood and so
actually survey don't know Sergey still
here sergey levine one of my colleagues
and i have started to talk quite a bit
because terms of the underlying
technical problems here there's a lot to
be shared so we don't have any notion of
dynamics in a real world but the
optimization you get when you're
searching for a policy and reinforcement
learning there's a little very very
similar techniques between what we're
doing and what they're doing and many of
the challenges as well which is i'll
tell you a little bit about and then the
other thing it's related to is image
generation so you've probably seen these
things of like taken network and i want
to know what an apple looks like or i
want to know what a bird looks like or i
want to create a man with glasses are
without glasses and these techniques are
also can be used here and some of the
challenges are similar as well i'm going
to talk more about those ok so what i
just described was our first sort of
stab at saying how can we do a sort of
in silico computational protein design
but something and we thought very clever
we account for uncertainty like we're
ready to go let's work with the lab so
what's what's going to go wrong
to an idea what's that what did Sammy
say I forget the stuff that you want
that you mean you don't move to the
right part of the space somehow er oh
the constraint so the constraints yeah
so one problem is the constraints but
sort of from ends and we can incorporate
those into the framework I just
described but sort of I think the main
problem is actually that we've assumed
the stochastic Oracle is unbiased and
has calibrated uncertainty estimates and
so what does everyone here know what
calibrated uncertainty estimates are so
just to be sure like if you have a
classifier and I tell you it's 0.8% I
can point a tack at then it better be
that if I have a hundred things with a
score of point eight cats then precisely
80% of them are cats now that's not true
then it's not calibrated and the less
true it is less calibrated and there's
an analogue for regression and we're
doing regression here but it's easier to
think about the classifications so what
really it means is these error bars have
meaning and all our experiments in the
preprint assumed that they were
calibrated because you know you always
hear for example that getting process
people talking about their lovely
uncertainty estimates but as you may
realize the further away you go from the
training data the more biased
essentially the model is right like kind
of like you like you can't extrapolate
indefinitely and so at some point you
have a bias model and if you have a
biased model then by definition the
uncertainty is not calibrated and so
you're kind of totally screwed and if
you do what we did you're just gonna go
into weird parts of the space and so and
more specifically if they're using a
neural network then there's all these
crazy weird pathologies that people now
know about and are trying to understand
and trying to fix and in strange ad-hoc
ways and these are gonna affect us
really really badly right so if you kind
of have these black holes in your model
and you're optimizing it you're gonna
probably fall into one of these black
holes because it's some total pathology
that tells you your protein intensity is
super-high and in fact it's just some
garbage black hole and what I mean by
black hole so it's this you know there's
different ways to demonstrate this one
is you take this tiny amount of noise
you get in a particular way by following
the gradient and you add it to an image
and
suddenly it turns into like a yield sign
even though perceptually it looks
identical right so we've all seen lots
of these examples but I can't resist I'm
going to show you a few anyway cuz I
really like them this case you have a
panda just add this tiny little bit of
no why is it still perceptually looks
like a panda but now with 99% confidence
is actually given this is what a Gibbon
looks like and then this one sort of is
pretty good so all the images in yellow
here have a greater than 50% chance of
being an airplane
according to like a network model and so
obviously if we're dealing with models
like this and we do this kind of thing
where we start with it one of these
models that's trained it has these weird
black holes and then we know this from
sort of the image generation right
people say what does a banana look like
in a train Network they propagate they
propagate the gradients back and
iteratively update X and then you get
this kind of weird stuff and it's
precisely because there's no we really
don't understand what's going on so then
if you're in the image generation game
you add you add constraints essentially
you put in prior knowledge to coerce it
to something that doesn't look like this
but obviously if we do something similar
we're gonna end up in some garbage part
of the space as well and so the
fundamental problem is how can we adapt
what we've done to somehow account for
this and I think is actually an
impossible problem but sort of all real
problems are impossible and we just like
to make as much progress as we can and
do better than you know directed
evolution which just got the Nobel Prize
or work synergistically with it of
course and I should mention usually by
now I have a question that says like why
isn't this just Bayesian optimization
but so or something like that where
you're dynamically trying to learn a
function so these are related but
they're also different so and if you're
wondering this just for those people in
Bayesian optimization every call to the
function is considered to be very
expensive and you're trying to in an
online manner decide how to trade-off
exploration exploitation to find the
next very expensive call here we're
assuming these calls are actually pretty
cheap and so it's not it's not although
there's a relationship between these
this isn't I would say this is the set
up is not Bayesian optimization so right
so now the second pass through is we
keep the same Google as we had before
and we add this fourth one which is
account for the fact that the Oracle may
be arbitrarily biased or pathological in
parts of the space ok so now now what do
we do
take banana with that sir hi we didn't
attack you yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yes
yes that's exactly right yes yes yes
exactly so we're gonna actually so David
David Brooks is my first PhD student
we've been doing all this work together
he and I think about this very
differently if he if he tells you what
is the solution is he'll describe it one
way and he'll say you just need a
condition usually estimate a conditional
density and it all tell you is you need
to be Bayesian and they're actually the
same thing but so I'll give you the
Bayesian flavor so what we're gonna do
is is say that imagine we have the data
that our predictive model was built on
that is pairs of x and y even though we
don't require it so there's two settings
in one case we're giving this and the
other I'll tell you what we do that but
legend were given this then basically
what we want is we want to use that data
to tell us where we believe that our
stochastic Oracle is trustworthy and
basically all we can believe is that
it's trustworthy near the training data
it's not some profound insight but it's
also a matter of even just incorporating
this and I would argue that the
framework we've built because it uses
this probability model as the search
model you can sort of naturally
incorporate it but in any case this
gives us prior knowledge of where we can
trust the model and where the
probability of Y given X is likely to be
accurate so how so basically we want to
do is estimate the density of the X's
from the tub that we're in the training
data and bring that into the method and
and this somehow tells us this is where
we expect input space to be trustworthy
for the stochastic Oracle that make
sense of course I'm gonna gloss over but
it requires that this itself is a good
estimate and there could be problems
there although I think in our experience
this is much less problematic than that
so right if we don't have access to
those data then we really become
Bayesian and we basically just say what
distribution of X's do we trust and and
by being when I say being Bayesian I'm
like we're really gonna just bring to
bear prior knowledge so for the example
in protein space we might say we we know
that like we can download online a list
of all proteins that are able to fold
and this would be almost the main
constraint here like us the thing that's
most likely to go wrong is you spit out
a protein that can't even fold
they can't fold for most purposes it's
not functional and so you could say well
what if we could just get it to fold and
so maybe what we do is we give it all
proteins that can fold and we learn a
density over those and instead of the
density of the training data we use that
and so or you can imagine some mix and
match of empirical based from the
training data plus adding in prior
knowledge okay so what do we do with the
prior you just use it with the Oracle to
get the joint essentially so this is the
Oracle probability of the property we
care about given the amino acid sequence
we just add in this new probability over
the space that we consider trustworthy
and that gives us the joint which is
proportional to the this conditional
density and this is why David likes to
describe it as a conditional density and
so now the game is actually to estimate
this conditional density and we're gonna
use similar techniques to what I
described but it's a little bit
different as well all sort of do an
outline of that so but one way to think
about this is you start with a
reasonable distribution of proteins
either from the draining data or from
your prior knowledge then you want a
condition on the event that you want so
for example X given that Y is greater
than Y max that the intensity is very
high and so an illustrative example of
this in our ICML paper is you started
with this is a little confusing because
the access is to purposes so this is the
training distribution this is actually
just a density P of X and this ground
truth is the actual true probability or
true Y for each X and so in this case we
have an Oracle
here but right so in this case right
this is the ground truth but we build an
Oracle right and the Oracle is never
perfect and then this this is one
version of an Oracle it's it's pretty
certain as you can see by its narrow
uncertainty in this case it's much
larger than this and and in this case
the ground truth coincides the peak
roughly with the Oracle and so if you
maximize the Oracle you're gonna be okay
there's not a problem but this is the
sort of thing I've been talking about is
these pathologies and of course this is
projected into a slide which is
one-dimensional so it's not actually
representative the crazy pathologies but
in this case the Oracle we build it just
keeps going up and so it's going to be
nowhere near the ground truth and so the
idea is if we incorporate this prior
knowledge and of course this is just a
schematic illustrative example of what
we hope we can accomplish then we can
now get an get it to sorry this case
right and in this case instead of it
going crazy like this we basically add
in the the P of X which reigns it in and
so it doesn't align exactly with the
maximum but at least it prevents us
basically from going crazy parts of the
space I don't know if this example
helped I'm actually presenting it all
that is to say is again that this adding
this distribution P of X should
hopefully coerce it to stay closer to
the area that we trust and so I
mentioned sort of I did an outline of
how we solve for example yes yeah
and so right so but again just the main
idea for everything I've said just to
include this extra P of X in there and
when you do that and you go through this
here you want to solve this conditional
density and so that's exactly the setup
so there's this conditional density that
we would like to estimate this one here
sorry probability of x given sorry this
one here this is the property we care
about we would like to estimate that and
we're gonna do that by using this
distribution and changing theta to
approximate it and minimizing the KL
divergence so I'm not gonna go through
all the technical details of that but
the methods are a little bit similar but
you get something that modulates the
weights which accounts for just prior
knowledge basically it ends up in the
weighting scheme of the weighted maximum
likelihood okay so the thing that's
really hard about this compared to most
machine learning problems is in most
machine learning problems that like
prediction of some kind classification
regression you can just hold out part of
the data and then you can see how well
you do and then you know if you're doing
domain adaptation and transfer learning
maybe like it's a bit more complicated
but you can always just kind of hold it
out and see what's going on in this case
it's really fundamentally hard sort of
as it is in combinatorial optimization
but it's even harder here for us to test
this than in combinatorial optimization
because we have this stochastic Oracle
that we know has pathologies in it and
we don't know where they are and so it's
really really hard to do in silico
experiments for this so we've done the
best we can but we have a number of wet
lab collaborations where we're going to
actually see if we can get somewhere
with this so we have to actually
simulate a ground truth and we're gonna
do that with a GP mean ground a Gaussian
process mean function and then that is
now our ground truth which we need and
you don't usually do and then from that
we can basically sample what we consider
to be observed nor corrupt data and then
build models on top of it and and then
the other thing we want to do is we want
to write give it just part like the the
lower part of the data lower part of the
intensity let's say and hide it from the
high intensity stuff this is also
different right we're sort of truncating
the space in some particular way and
anyway when we do that then we can do
some simulations I'm not gonna go into a
lot of detail of of what emerges but
I'll just say that there's there are a
suite of methods you can use here some
of which we've developed or some are
generalizations or specific
instantiations of other things you could
think to use and in the end they're all
very similar in that you generate
samples from a generative model and then
you do a weighted maximum likelihood
update and the weights are just all
different for these and that's kind of
how these things are different from each
other and then we also test it against
some gradient face methods and this is
again what people an image generation do
right they take a neural network and
they fix the output it says like show me
a banana and then they use gradients to
optimize the inputs so I'm not gonna go
into all these details I think but I'll
just say that so this is kind of where
we're at now we've introduced a new
model based optimization that accounts
for uncertainty in the Oracle and as
hopefully he some extent robust to these
pathologies but I think this is one of
the sort of open challenges for us is
how to do that and I'll say a bit more
in a second but right now we're also in
parallel so we're developing these
methods and publishing them technical
papers but we have a number of
collaborations where we're doing this
with a wet lab so you dub for protein
binding unstability there's a really
wonderful guy David Shafer here at
Berkeley who does gene delivery like
trying to get proteins in a particular
part of the eye to cure certain forms of
blindness and getting the protein to the
right space requires designing
that protein in a very particular way
and as I mentioned we're starting also
to work on small molecule design with a
pre-competitive consortium called atom
and there's also some interesting
organic synthetic chemistry here but so
what may be may be what is in it for the
theoreticians in the room who there
might be interesting problems here so
one thing that's been interesting to me
is to think about extrapolation so we're
taking an Oracle and we know we want to
extrapolate right we're trying to do
maximization and so by definition were
extrapolating and so I remember I don't
know if her still here I was trying to
understand what theoretical results were
understood about this and I went into
Peter Bartlett's office and and I said
something about extrapolation and he
said what's that I said thank you I no
one else has given me this answer and I
think it's the right answer it's like
what is extrapolation you know you show
it in whatever in grade school or
whatever in introductory math like this
thing like this where you have data and
extrapolations out here but what is out
here and how do you define that crisply
if someone knows I would really like to
know the answer I have yet to be given
any reasonable answer to this and I
think for us that's it's it's very
important to understand actually crisply
what that means and how can we
practically use that definition I think
it make I to us in particular ways so
the other thing is is how can we
essentially what we're doing is like a
particular form of domain adaptation
right which is for maximization and
that's a very specific one and I don't
know if people have ever if you're aware
of work where people have done it just
for that purpose I'd like to know about
that but and also moreover lauda that
works not sort of geared towards deep to
neural networks and they're weird
pathologies and things like this so I
think that's another interesting problem
is how to do that and then beyond that
this is one that I think is typically
overlooked is people do all these things
to make models better but they don't
really look carefully at when the
uncertainty is calibrated and when you
can trust them and we really really care
about that because we're just gonna go
completely wrong if we don't know how
far to trust the model so this is super
super important to us in fact we'd
rather err on the side of being
conservative and truckin and Trust
having that trust region to small
because otherwise we're just gonna get
crazy stuff in or her collaborators are
gonna walk
way and then I've mentioned this so we
spend quite a bit of time looking at the
work on deep neural networks and
calibration of uncertainty I'd say these
are sort of two of my favorite papers
and but I think they're sort of the
beginning of the story it's not a new
story right people this tau de cision
z-- especially been working on
calibration for decades but we have yet
to find very practical useful things for
that purpose and so I think there's a
lot of interesting work there as well my
colleagues or so David is my first
student he's really you know I've been
driving these projects everything I
mentioned here all three of these and
acaso and Clara are my group as well and
I didn't talk about the last paper of
this relationship to
expectation-maximization as well as
Kevin and hun bums a protein scientist
at u-dub who helped us through one in
the same right like it's a well you can
in you can actually do both with this
right so to the extent you understand it
you can encode this understanding and
Oracle and we can absorb that so and one
reason I like this is I don't want to
like be in this likes position of like
no no we don't need I want to take as
much outside knowledge as we can in as
much mechanistic understanding but
people have been chasing this for
decades and it's largely unsolved and so
yeah that would be great I think if you
you know if there's like a
million-dollar contest of who's gonna
get this protein I think this is gonna
win over that on average for all
problems maybe particular problems for
which there is good knowledge but we'd
like part of this is to precisely go
beyond that and so in fact David Baker's
lab at the University of Washington
they're like the you know sort of
leaders in the field of particular
protein things that are very very
related to structure and free energy and
doing physics based simulations but
there's there are many properties for
which this isn't going to get you very
far and so yeah if you if you're in
those niche areas than your right and in
general this would be lovely but I think
this is a long way out and I think the
best you can do is actually develop
methods and I think it's like
probabilistic ones where you can
coherently incorporate this into the
method design examples are going to be
yeah sorry yes I don't think we have a
problem of adverse sailing examples the
reason I put that there because I think
they're sort of a very nice way to
highlight pathologies of the model it
says that there's parts of the space the
model just doesn't understand and yet we
may not hit those but there are lots of
these holes and and you can see them
easily in this way so it's sort of a
very nice visual striking way to
understand crazy pathologies and you're
right like there's not an adverse I mean
it's unlikely there's an adversary in
our system but the same pathologies that
allow yeah yeah oh I see yeah yeah right
yeah it's not yeah not adversarial II
just sort of accidentally prig because
it's these sort of like black holes yeah
exactly yeah there's a very direct
connection to policy gradient absolutely
except we don't have the dynamics again
it's really early days for us we have we
have these are just budding
collaborations we have not yet actually
tested anything in the lab
let's speak again
[Applause]